there are some celebrities that are very
and the steve aoki is huge in the space
you know and every time they do a drop
blast what is huge
beats and sound well they're working on
music nfts now but they do a lot of
pfp's photos as well
um and and it's going to evolve over
time so it'll go into music nfts it'll
go into gaming nfts i actually advise on
a gaming nft right now and then you know
hopefully long form like comedy film tv
i think that we'll be seeing
more of that in the future
everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do the show
directly right my
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
[Music]
so it was
it was good stuff and willie
you know we did this all together so
willie
still sings
there's no way that dude is in the 60s
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm 72 and we
got well maybe he's early 70s
oh maybe you're talking about willie
nelson uh no a guy named almost 90.
you know let's say god gives you one
tank of gas
and
maybe sometimes
you
my tank is really low i'm getting
everything you saw my you saw me running
my tank is already running low
i mean
especially because you got that haircut
there's a lot of analogies
yeah my banana is brown
is that what is it
getting up there right banana older
brown oh man
i buy fruit at the house just so it
looks like a normal person lives there
does it work
yeah they think it's bad
i should just do what i told that
community one time don't you just go get
some tennis balls and paint them orange
so you don't have to buy oranges every
week
hilarious
um not a bad idea are we are we rolling
we're rolling okay i'm turning it off
sir you're not chained up later on i'm
not going to hey man listen there you go
yeah
silence are good
it's not
the silent part i've got
the ring you got that ring and every
time somebody goes by and go by the door
it rings
and so they live up to it you know
um
i've never looked paler in my life
ever
i'm like am i blending in with the wall
like i'm i look like a ghost haunting in
the studio what part of the country is
this ghost from
i'm from new york
you're from new york yes born in queens
oh okay george born in queens
where would we find such a woman
where would you find a new york jew
um
what what would you consider yourself
what is your occup
so many wonderful things to talk about
uh so i mean what i have down here is
comedian actress clubhouse aficionado
nft guru and host of the real-time crime
podcast thank you
works for me
yeah and the most recent person banned
on tick tock thank you yeah
congratulations yeah i anger gen z i
don't know and tick tock won't tell me
but i think
i don't know i have no idea what it
could have been maybe one person that
says hey i saw this
they have young people that are making
decisions over there i would assume i
assume it's um the wokest 18 year old
who's just going through my tic tac i
have no idea what it could have been
except for maybe my kova jokes or
abortion jokes but other than that i
have no idea
hey jokes are jokes yeah you would think
[Laughter]
i got a visit from the secret service of
the united states
a little over two years ago
for something i said
what did we say george told my
grandmother go [ __ ] herself one time
she hit me she didn't raise her voice oh
oh yeah okay
okay her voice actually came down oh
i wish i knew she was really mad go [ __ ]
yourself
okay
all right
what did the secret service want
uh
right wait a minute don't tell me
shocking you spoke about the president
they wanted to go on a date with you
no they didn't drink you know
i guess i guess i could before this
podcast blows up i guess i'll say
that
you know i really was i really have not
been a uh comedian that
um
i mean i didn't really follow anybody's
path like if i made my own path
you know whatever
i mean my idols were black comedians so
i couldn't
really do that
there was very few latino guys i just
kind of made my own
but
you all know what i said yeah
we'll cut this out like rick glassman
cut and then we'll start
um
i was uh i was maybe
i was leaving the chateau marmont
and my phone wasn't on and i turned it
on i was having with lunch with cedric
and his family and it said
that iran had offered 80 million dollars
on a bounty for president trump
and then i said we'll do a perhaps
and when i got home that's just good
guys my publicist called me and she said
where are you are you home are you alone
can you talk
[Laughter]
i said what i do now dude what did you
say where where have you been
where have you been i was having lunch
what did you say
i what just tell me just tell me what i
did
and then it got on the news and then fox
is like having
an older sibling that doesn't like
you want the parents to put the screws
to you like yeah don't get away with
that [ __ ] i didn't get away with it why
let him get away with it and then
fox jumps on
and then they
stoke their fires and then
you see that that i could have expected
george lopez could expect a visit from
the secret service in the next week and
that
they were they were right
that's hilarious i had my attorney with
me
and they said did you think that this is
funny
i said what are you talking about what
are you talking about they go this and
they said they had everything that we
ever put on social media all of us
everything
and he held up a picture of uh
el chapo holding up the head of donald
trump and i said what is that
you reach are you retweeted this did i
think that's funny
no i don't i mean maybe when i did it i
thought it was funny but right now
so you know
they were there to test whether i was a
you know and it's ridiculous because
there's bigger things going on in this
world than
i i tell you that's making jokes
into my house i don't know what car joe
rogan uh drives call me a web bank no
i was in dc doing some
uh master ceremonies work back
there and our keynote speaker was the
surgeon general who's a puerto rican out
of new york who is now residing in
arizona
and can i say this am i responsible for
this
and i say this to you would you listen
to a puerto rican from new york
about what i bought
other than where did you know what ball
digger can you do you know where to eat
sure yeah
you can go to overthink and buy one egg
he was uh he was there he said some
stuff and then they left
and about a half hour later i'm getting
called and
people that were with him
part of his staff or some calling to
apologize to make sure nobody was
offended some of the watching i said
nobody was offended at anything he said
you know he didn't say anything in
general he could say you know and they
were just
making sure that every word was right
they listened to everything he says they
followed me around wow he hated uh he
didn't like being a certain general he
says back here he said no surgeon
general sounds like an ex-girlfriend
trying to stab you in the back you don't
wash your hands as much as you should i
don't no yeah no i mean
listen we've gotten to that point where
where everything is scrutinized
everything from the past can be brought
back up
in some situations but uh usually if you
realize you're
doing something wrong along the way you
either uh you know stop doing it or
people that bring [ __ ] up from the third
grade
you know they they remember that first
kiss they remember everything
looks like someone went to detention
there ain't nothing safe
now i know
how hurt i am because the secret service
hasn't knocked on my door yeah it's like
i'm not i'm not really rocking the boat
enough or that's the next level but
listen i didn't get thrown off tick tock
that's the right talk is the cia of gen
z
do you know that okay so let's say that
let's say that as as people are out
there there used to be when the internet
first started when there was less social
media
men would pretend to be
girls
to try to lure girls out of their homes
sometimes it was working sometimes it
didn't but
you had to be aware that there was a
faction of these men
or people who are deranged one of them
started this company okay i was watching
the documentary yeah i was watching you
heard about the tunnels underground
right it's a playboy shirt for the
listening audience underneath the yeah
the playboy mansion house wait no i
haven't oh lord you know i went down a
very dark conspiracy hole the other
night
but also there were tunnels underneath
there were tunnels underneath the
playboy mansion connected to all wealthy
people's houses in the area so
there's like a sex trafficking scandal i
don't know you know what i the cia is
coming after me tonight
you heard it here where did you where
did you i guess it's all
it's all hey it's all hearsay it's all
maybe allegedly
but you know that but it is true that it
you know that you were a police officer
in the 30s there was a mobster who
bought a house on sunset and shirley
temple
lived in that house at one time and he
has a full bank
a safe a full safe
wells fargo with the big thing then you
open it up and it's that thick with with
one of those in a house down below
and to the left of it is a tunnel that
goes across the street
and out into a small area i guess where
you would probably take your dogs and
out of there because that guy was a
mobster and he wanted to make sure that
if his house
was raided he had a place to to go so i
would say i'm not sure del sol but i
think bugsy siegel had a place out here
that may have been on here that may have
been him i thought you were going to say
the tunnel went right to walt disney's
house
we're gonna go a lot of places in this
tunnel here
no no but but but i think that you know
uh um you know there's there's that
faction of it you know there's a fashion
of people that
so i i was looking on tick tock i don't
really look at tick tock a lot but i
wouldn't i would i would say
anymore what happens when you go on
there what's there
well
literally i got a notification last
night
at midnight that said
we have looked at your account and
reviewed it and decided that you have
violated so many oh my god
you've had so many actions of misconduct
that we cannot repeal your action and
you're banned
but it's weird because i still have my
account but then other people look at my
account has zero views across the board
also they just kind of wiped your slate
but what's weird
is that i started tick tock three weeks
ago
and i blew up to 57 000 followers in
three weeks
i feel like it's the only platform you
can actually go viral on it seems like
he wants to use mine
i think i think you're doing fine george
no i mean
i don't think you want my content unless
you want to get banned um
what took you so long ago to get to tick
tock
to be honest when tick-tock started
blowing up i got very into clubhouse and
i was on the app 24-7 and there was just
not much else i could do besides
constantly talk i was talking
24 7. i had two phones running at the
same time one in my closet oh man trying
to collect followers i mean if you want
to know just how mentally ill i was
if i had a third phone i would have used
it
so
wow
yeah but i was on that app constantly
but were you always the type of person
that was
talking or yes yes yeah and then i
eventually became the icon of clubhouse
and you are the iconic well i was
no longer no longer you're on clubhouse
aren't you
yes
liza
got me into that clubhouse you know
eliza which liza
uh oh blizzard
yeah yeah i know liza with twozies yes
yeah she's great oh they got me i'm
realistic is that your last name i think
so yeah um
god there's so much to you're gonna edit
this one pretty pretty tight aren't you
because there's just so many things to
ask like
what
what is the function of clubhouse it's a
great question the the function of
clubhouse is social audio as its own
platform
and so
it would be like calling a place up and
saying can i have the uh
can i talk to somebody in sales hey you
know i'm trying to start this thing is
that what it is right you get kind of
yeah you get good advice because there's
so many people in the room that if it's
not good advice they're going to go
that's [ __ ] you can't do that right
do this so so everybody kind of keeps
each other in check and the [ __ ]
maybe it's down low
matter of fact i went on clubhouse when
i was at my place yeah and they found
this old this kid this
uh joe verdu who was
a long time
let's say i'll call him an associate of
mine back in the day when i was working
outside that's right very touching for
me the guy's gone from bad to good
matter of fact he's displaying right now
as much as they are on his way out here
again right now to go to the super bowl
can you can you say what this what this
uh man did in his life and what and how
redeeming without mentioning his name
the man
his brother was a uh parole officer
and he was not such a good person in the
neighborhood
and
i was lecturing
i ran into his brother at this lecture
room and
they asked me you ever handled murders
out here i say yeah i got a double herb
out here we just arrested the perp the
suspect who had been in mexico they got
him coming across it's about a
three-year-old murder i said now i got
to hustle find witnesses you know
prosecute
and i was told
my brother saw this
and but my brother won't talk to you
my brother's different he's now found
the lord
i said i don't care
i won't bother him
here's my card haven't give me a call to
solve a murder yeah
and so his brother did
the bottom line his brother was there
matter of fact one of the deceits died
in his arms
and i told him none of this will be used
without your permission
and he says well i'm going to talk to
the lord about this skill
i don't know that i can do this
and i started smiling with a little
chuckle
and he said i'm serious
he thought because religiously it would
be go against him he didn't say why he
just said he had to talk to the lord
about it because he knew
by coming out if he helped me
that would not be acceptable in the old
neighborhood you know that's he that's
not good then know being
that they'd just label them a rat you
know yeah and so
i thought about that when i was a kid i
smiled before but i
said it's it's okay
and
i said i'm not laughing at you
i'm laughing because i'm happy
oh because i know
if i wasn't going to get the information
the lord wouldn't have brought me to you
today
so he did
so i'll just wait for your phone call
and about an hour two hours later he
called me up
bottom line the guy came through the guy
changed his entire life i kept up with
him out there helped him out of
some minor scrapes back there out in the
streets the guy moved got into the
ministry did that for a while
then he got into this
big league he'd buy one of the
uh
websites
you buy a website you know uh what are
they called domains
he got into domain buying years ago
you think he's not sitting fat and happy
today one of his domains
was la rams
what when the rams when the rams i need
to find the lord yeah
no talk about coming back to l.a right
he just bought the domain how can
somebody do that how can somebody
buy the don't buy all you do is register
nobody's got it out there
and it's yours
and then
these people come back
and i'm not saying the rams did it but
other
people
they come back and they want that domain
because
that's money for them and they don't
want you using
so
they pay big
bucks in the resale of that domain
and so he's made a living
you know we sound like we're 150 years
old right now
yeah
and god bless him the guy's good he's a
friend
he's that he's what's he doing with his
money
saving it yeah is he single yeah he's
no very married has kids grandkids
yeah he uh
just invest you know business like that
he send me i showed a picture he sent me
some pictures of his new house this was
last year
i mean it's it's not a house it's a
mansion it's like a hotel i mean
big property beautiful everything you
know something that i could never afford
living and
not locally he's back
i don't know where he's at he's
someplace
that side of
back in the midwest someplace
but he's doing fine how old is he
uh
he's probably in his early 60s
i was already working murdered by the
time i got to him and he was already
through his teens so so but i would say
in your as your in your life as a
detective you're probably not allowed to
allow somebody to know who killed
somebody and then let them not testify
i would think that would be against the
law well it you you know right you have
to have seemed like it would be
like you know and you go i'm not going
to tell you guys
okay
well there is no you can play the game
are you a good cop and bad cop
all you do is write it up just like he
said it and then you say it's an
anonymous informant
and you call him an anonymous informant
now
they can force me
they can't force him to talk
like nobody could do that
so then it's up to me
to be gil carrillo to get him talk and
open up
so
i i call my anonymous informant my fake
instagram where i stock my exes from
they're like how did you find this out
i'm like no clue just uh someone else's
instagram have you ever started a
network
just on the internet
i'm not i'm not doing drive-bys but you
go and find out things about where they
might be and all that i mean just
curious to know who they're with
thank you that's yeah yeah yeah i feel
like i'm gonna look like a psycho girl
generational yeah who hasn't done that
yeah that's i mean come on that's it's
2022. we've all looked
right it's tempting it's hard you've got
to like there's a whole like politics of
like muting or blowing
up restricting them
is it more is it more difficult because
from the safety of your home you can
pretty much
find out where they are what they're if
they're posting
yeah where they are and who they're with
yeah it's very easy to make yourself sad
yeah oh
yeah yeah we're all very millennials are
so sad i don't care about anybody i
don't want to do that because once you
do it's there they can find out
everything they want up here can i tell
you when i was in high school i was in
my girlfriend's kitchen
looking at some pictures she loved to
take pictures
and she was looking over my shoulder and
she grabbed one
of her and a guy holding hands and i
said what's this well that was from a
few years ago
i also did some detective work
she was wearing it he was wearing a
t-shirt from a concert that had just
happened a couple weeks earlier
so i saw that there and now where's her
so what happened
so what was your next move
i left the house and then
um
wow the detective asked a question
all right what do you think guilty or
not guilty
i don't know i mean you know i still
talk to her a little bit but um god the
alibi is getting real thin
her is not in my trunk
okay so so
where do we go here well speaking of
buying domains let's yes let's talk
about buying domains well so i'll tell a
little bit about web 3 domains
if we want to go there let's do that
i've never heard of web3 everybody have
you
yeah so and you're probably welcome to
have set up too explain it but we're
currently on business like the third no
oh my god thank you so much though
um no i was a biochem major which is
also do you think i'm in college
you're very young you're too intelligent
she's young
i find it hard to believe
right now
you're
a comedian
actress i can buy but thank you
comedians i mean
to look at you now you know everything
is in place i mean the you're you're
very you're not worn from smoky rooms
filled and boozed drinking what do they
say that you look like very pretty
i get lady gaga yes i get chelsea
yeah you do
she's beautiful
no no i love her i love her i just don't
want to look like
loki
no i think she's probably one of the
most talented people on planet earth so
that's a very high compliment because i
know you're talking about my talent not
my appearance so
okay i've never been married
[Laughter]
okay so web 3 is the newest version of
the internet which is considered
excellence of the internet
so
it is the metaverse aky mark zuckerberg
changed facebook to meta because
everyone will be buying land in the
future
in the metaverse in a
imagined reality that we all agree to
while it's virtual reality augmented
reality or
internet hyper augmented reality which
we consider the metaverse so
people how are we doing so far you know
that
i i have
someone degree of awareness are we still
going to be using toilet paper at that
time i mean did you see ready player one
because i think that's where we're
headed to and so we're i'm preparing
mentally and emotionally and physically
to actually be a landowner in the fake
world while still just living in a tiny
studio
in this world i'm gonna be so rich in
the fake world you have no idea what is
it yeah like virtual real estate is is a
thing half of my net worth is in the
metaverse so four dollars but
but i will tell you this i so so let's
go back a little bit because we were
talking about domains
so ens domains is the term is is the
term behind any sort of domain that you
would buy on web3 so everything has a
dot ethe at the end you can buy a dot
xyz a dot nft whatever it is most people
get dot eth which is for ethereum which
is the second most popular
cryptocurrency
after bitcoin i'm so sorry gil i know
this is that you know let's go back to
talking about true crime because i do
have a true crime podcast uh on i heart
radio called real-time crime and i'd
love to talk about that with you
especially talk about amanda knox but um
we're gonna do that right now as soon as
you unconfuse us
okay so so
just how
gil's friend who found the lord bought
domain names in web 2 ak.com era right
someone purchased leah lamar.eth
which would be my domain and now is
trying to charge me one each which is
around well right now it's around 3000.
but it was about 4 400. the price
dropped um it's on sale
they purchased my domain so i'd have to
buy it from them so i just purchased
lamar.eth because i was like [ __ ] that
guy but they also purchased kris jenner
dot eth whitney cummings dot eth tim
dillon dot east donnell rawlings
so i'm in good company
but i didn't buy it back from him
he can just keep it yeah because that's
the risk you run if you're like domain
squatting is the other person can be
like [ __ ] you right and but but i also
know that people have mistakenly sent
that address eth or nfts because they
didn't realize it wasn't my domain so
that's also a risk i run by not
purchasing it
[Music]
but i have purchased over 30 nfts and
i'm very in the web 3 community i've
lost my mind i sometimes look at my
phone and i i woke up at 5 00 a.m this
morning to mint a cool pet
now let me show you something right now
so that we can all get on the same page
of how odd this is okay so i woke up at
5 a.m to buy
this
all right okay all right it is a oh
[Laughter]
it's a
drawing of an egg
so it's an egg of what will hatch to be
a cartoon of a baby cat
and i spent around
2 500 on that
my dad's gonna disown me
we can we can bleep the
but the thing is that it's already worth
six thousand dollars
just one this morning just from this
morning and it hasn't even hatched yet i
hate myself now wow wow wow that whole
sentence really felt bad but um this is
my truth so how long does it take for it
to hatch or like what is that that
process well so just for reference like
these are a bunch of the nfts that i own
and
scrolling through her empty wallet well
this is only one of many wallets i have
um and they're all just pfps just photos
for the most part but
this is just the inception of
the future right now they're doing music
nft so nos dropped an nft and a lot of a
lot of musicians are starting to drop
their music on here because you get
royalties every time there's a resale
okay and you skip the agent fee you skip
the manager fee unless you have a web3
agent or manager
basically you're getting all of the
money from your project okay
so here um
i was i went to corpus christi
on friday
and my daughter's 25 and she wanted to
go to the selena museum which was closed
because of the pandemic but they said
that
mr quintanilla abraham coutinho would
meet us there
and he would give us a tour a private
tour just him and somebody that you know
goes with him yeah so
there's music in there that no one's
ever heard from selena wow there's music
that
was new that never was released and then
there's
possibility of nfts there
anniversary
so
what
and i was trying to tell him about it
but you know i don't i don't know
anything about it what would your advice
be to him
i would say that he should drop each
individual song as a one of one
which means instead of a ten thousand
piece collection which most of these are
it would just be a one piece and either
it could be an auction because you know
sotheby's is on here christie's is on
here everyone has come into the
metaverse you know it's not just for d
gens now
internet folk who are obsessed with i
don't even know djents what's that like
degeneres is that yeah okay
but but it's not in a negative way it
just means you stay up late on your
phone
you're buying somebody just
yeah and so um
if you sell it as a one of one either
it could be an auction and the price
will just go up and up and up or you
could set it at a certain price
and whoever buys it and that price would
be extremely high i would say yeah it
could be
released it could be whatever it is and
the thing that's interesting about
the entire nft experience is that a lot
of it is based on hype
as my friend naval robbie khan said
this is the ponzi scheme of our
generation
however
however
what's so interesting about it is the
contract behind it
so
you
are able to show ownership over the
token or the good that you receive and
most of these have utility so why people
are so obsessed with board apes for
example is that it becomes a social club
and you get ticketed to private events
that everyone wants to go to
you know chris rock dropped in at their
event in
nyc and nft
and
that's why people want to be part of
these clubs because it's a very
specific social club that feels elite
and you have to buy it at a super high
price and people like being around other
wealthy people who have their same
interests and that's why dave chappelle
bought one that's why 11 the nightclub
in miami bought one you know that's what
all these people are buying them because
they want to be part of this elite club
how much are they spending for them
i think it's a minimum of like
90 eth right now
i could be wrong about that but i would
say 250 thousand dollars is the minimum
for one
let's take the corn or flour tortillas
it's much simpler
but but look right i'm not going to say
which network but a friend had a
because i would love to have a special
with them but a friend dropped a half
hour special her first special
and
it was worth 25 000 after agent fees
after manager fees after taxes i think
she walked away with 7 500
for a half hour special
if you dropped
a half hour special on the blockchain
and put it in pieces this is what i'll
be doing i'm going to drop my hour
special and cut it up into specific
jokes so people could buy
jokes
you would make
minimum i mean this is not financial
advice and you know you can't predict
the future but if people are buying your
jokes at one eath and you have 60 of
them i mean you're making over 100k
minimum just from the primary sale and
then when people resell them you're
getting royalties off of each one just
like residual checks from sag-aftra
so some people make millions of dollars
most people make can make up to 20
million from the first drop that they do
wow
it's insane they've dave crust
no he's just releasing he's doing like
the the sort of louis model where you
just just release it on your site and i
think it's a fixed fee some people do
pay what you will but it's like say five
bucks and then boom you get his full
special i watched louie's new special
and i loved it did you watch it
he did the same thing right he keeps
releasing on his website
yeah and he does it in bundles too where
you could just buy the special or you
could buy that and where is he shooting
where did he shoot it i don't know where
louis shot sorry i'll see if i can check
it out yeah but you know what it was
probably one of the best specials i've
seen in a while i watched aziza special
at the cellar the half hour one and then
i watched louise back to back and
louie's hour special was just joke joke
joke joke
from sorry is it that
hilarious also you know i respect anyone
who can make two 911 jokes funny
yeah i have to check it out
interesting it's another did i just bore
you guys no no it's another world it's
another world
yeah i think just lots of pride it's one
of those things where it's hard
like math like you really have to get
each bit of it to get there well the
other the other thing is that the
community is so bullish on the community
so sometimes people from outside will
come in just to drop to capitalize on
making cash
and the community doesn't like that you
know right but they police themselves
and say if you're going to be in here
be with us instead of just right like
you know i don't think people love
people who just want to cash grab they
want people who actually are into the
community
but you know paris hilton is super in
the community every time she does a drop
she
sells out completely and does amazing
she has a new drop coming up with origin
protocol soon
and there are some celebrities that are
very in the steve aoki is huge in the
space you know and every time they do a
drop blast what does he drink
beets and sound well they're working on
music nfts now but they do a lot of
pfp's photos as well
um and and it's going to evolve over
time so to go into music nfts it'll go
into gaming nfts i actually advise on a
gaming nft right now and then you know
hopefully long form like comedy film tv
i think that we'll be seeing
more of that in the future tim dillon
was talking on joe rogan podcast about
how he's making a feature film putting
it on the blockchain and having it
completely financed by bitcoin
so i think that's in the future
i don't think that web 3 was ready for
it in the past year i don't think they
were ready for long-form content but now
they're starting to get used to the idea
of music so it's like one to three
minutes then moving on to
gail i'm so sorry you just own that
small piece and somebody's trying to
trying to collect the whole special i
just like a small piece i love it
right yeah yeah it's pretty amazing i
mean there's just so many possibilities
and i think this is just the beginning
of it and you're still early if you get
in now so to speak
uh you know it's before any platform
blows up you know now it's super hard to
if you if you just started youtube today
you know you'd be playing catch up to
everyone who's been doing it for years
and years like literally saying and all
these you know monsters on there right
but
web 3 is still young it's still very
early
so anyone want to kill themselves
no i think it's not and i think too i
think the audience is really interested
in this stuff too and it's just you lost
heart right after hello
how about that that gill may have the
suit that he wore
when he captured the the night stalker
wait
so what so i don't know how much
research time you had but gail is the
gentleman who caught the night stalkers
i also need to have you on my podcast
let's go
i'm going to be talking jpf and
jpl and nfd and he was the first he was
the first officer that said it's the
same guy when everybody said it was
multiple people
wow
and he captured him kayla's true crime
royalty
true crime royalty
i mean i have a thousand questions i
also just want to
finish the web 3 conversation on this
yes please so one last thing so as all
these big organizations are coming
nike's doing a drop adidas but light
just did a drop everyone's coming on
board now trying to capitalize on the
market
time magazine was on board before anyone
and they are cherished in the community
and time started awarding people
for being present in the community but
also outside the community so because i
was a robotos holder which is a specific
nft wow they did a collaboration with
time and i was awarded entertainer of
the year for 2021.
time magazine
thank you i'll never be on the cover of
time outside web 3 but in web 3.
everybody's going into whip web 3. i
mean you're ahead of your time
you're like the first female president
in web 3.
thank you and what's quite an honor to
have what is the breakdown of like web
1.0 2.0
like web 1.0 was was basically
aol the dial-up generation
web 2 is everyone sending emails
constantly google searching
that's web2
web and you know gaming irl web 3
is now
the metaverse buying land in the
metaverse you know i think oculus if you
ever wore the vr headsets
they're fine right but i think that
there is a little bit of an entry a
barrier to entry with the oculus i have
one but it's a little cumbersome and
it's heavy and it's expensive and
i think that will happen in the future
is that people will just have contacts
or glasses that are very lightweight
where you can be talking to someone and
in a digital realm at the same time or
literally scanning their face and it
googles them as you're standing next to
them
and that's where we're headed
and that's considered ar right like
augmented that's considered right yeah
certainly certain indeed
that's where you're getting both in real
life and but gil tell us about your life
because it's actually important
you'll be able to be at woodstock
just like it was to be there right
honestly yeah we're creating yes you can
be in the front row would suck i will
tell you i've tried vr porn because i
was just so curious
i
and the girls were
huge because you're wearing it and it's
the whole screen so i'm just like oh my
god these are giants you know but i
don't know how profane i could be on
here so i'll just keep it peachy oh you
can be his profanity oh i got my dick
sucked as a guy it was hilarious right
suddenly i looked down and i had a dick
and it was getting sucked by these giant
women and i was like i see why someone
would like this you know
i'm not i'm not interested in your
guys's face
i'm not interested and i'll never work
for walmart okay um i'm not interested
seriously in anything about porn but
some of my friends might be so how do
they get this yeah you're asking for a
friend
so you saw it you saw it with your
own bri yes yes and and now like the
technology they have with the vr it's
like anyone can get an oculus quest for
like 300 bucks yeah you get on amazon it
comes out of the box you don't need to
hook it up to anything it's just ready
to go
it's really cool get your dick sucked in
10 minutes yeah i mean less less than
that yeah somebody's showing me how
i should have brought it with me
about this you can feel it in your mind
well unless you have someone there with
you um oh that would be wild and also
[Laughter]
that's
fascinating
yeah it's fascinating what what what the
world will be nobody will see anybody
else
in 20 years everybody will be tucked
away somewhere thank god
yeah i miss march 2020 honestly
right and with fantastic air and just
perfect climate and you'll just
go around the world you know sometimes
when you go into vr they'll put you in
your home place before you start
selecting what you want to do and i'm
like this is nicer than any home i'll
ever own you know i feel wealthy beyond
measure you know the view is
unbelievable i'm i'm watching
you know balloons take off in the sky as
i'm sitting in my mansion and i'm like
if only they knew i was on my toilet
right like instead like when you turn on
your computer and you see like that
windows backdrop right it's instead of
that you're in like a beautiful swiss
chalet
i love this lady
i love this lady
she's real
yeah i mean i have no reason not to be
well you know as p as people go away
uh and they are recreated in the virtual
world
there will be less people who could say
that they saw
ronald reagan
um
in person at the white house or
uh the second bush or met gerald ford
bill clinton
campaign for barack obama you could do
that in the virtual world but
in the real world now there'll be less
of those opportunities because as we get
people will do that
uh as politics and as tv and as
communication
right
and then the eyes they realize that see
things
that people will be recreating will no
longer exist
thank god
go back to his mfts or
what do you think like i saw you know i
gave you that ball from tony larussa
right
he albert pujols
i could call tony russo right now you
could talk to him but not in the virtual
world
well he can meet us there
people are having work meetings
that's kind of like the hope of
zuckerberg right like when he talks meta
metaverse stuff it's like you know you
put on a helmet and you have a meeting
with someone as if they're in the same
room as you right
i'm just confused why he doesn't have
personality coaching you know when i
watch videos of him i'm like why am i
watching the lizard king what's
happening yeah i do that with people's
teeth like you know people that have a
lot of money you're like why does this
[ __ ] have like some
some broken fence you have the resource
sticks and you're in this yeah i once i
went to a dentist and i wanted to get
invisalign which i have right now
and his teeth were so janky i was like
i'm not gonna let you work on my mouth
yeah you don't even take care of your
own man right
forever yeah
okay so that that's that's that part of
it
but they will be able to bring people
back to life
that are no longer amongst the living
that we know of that we know is that
like what's that stuff they uh they do
they put napkin coal and uh
there's daughter together hologram
hologram is that going to be that's an
allogram stuff
that's what that's nothing compared
george has decided that's nothing
i mean that's
it it'll be like us sitting here
don't you think yeah absolutely when you
got your dick sucked did it look like
the guy was the girl was right in front
of you yes
and she was so big
i will say the girls weren't that
attractive
you know i was like if i was a guy i
might have been disappointed
really yeah i'm like if this is my dream
situation
that's just gonna happen once
but look at what she's getting i mean
she could say oh god you should have
seen the guy
[Laughter]
okay that's those are two that's two
things down
now let's go to crime
i'm gonna go ahead and pay for this how
did how did you start
how did you
um was anybody in law enforcement in
your family no entertainment
yes
oh
keep going okay so who's in
entertainment okay so this is
i'll take this question in two pieces so
the first question no one in my family
was in law enforcement but there was a
murder in my immediate family
and so i've always been very
i don't even know how to phrase it um i
just i have so many questions around
murder why someone would murder someone
what the brain of a killer is like what
the brain of a serial killer is like you
know and i think as women a lot of
female comics have jokes about how you
know women love to watch serial killer
documentaries it's like we want to know
what someone might do so that we don't
do that thing to get murdered right
you know we want to it's like in the
beginning of every scary movie where the
girl like trips over a banana and you're
like come on get up get up you know it's
like okay so make sure there are no
bananas on the floor tie my shoes you
know have mace whatever it is
um
but that's why i've always been really
interested in it because i always seek
answers
and i think this is why most of my
relationships end
because i'm always like did you date her
yesterday or not i like are you in love
with someone else you know i ask a lot
of questions um which to be fair
i think is reasonable
you should ask a lot of questions
yeah right okay so that's number one
number two um i'm a distant cousin of
hedy lamarr
um who
yeah yes he was a film actress in the
40s she also escaped nazi germany and
she discovered wi-fi i was going to say
it was she discovered wi-fi
yeah yeah she discovered frequency
hopping remember uh
blazing saddles
yes when harvey korman walks into the
grandma's chinese and they go look
hattie lamarr and he doesn't even break
stride he goes headley
bob used to refer to hedy lamarr
all the time in his uh when he toured
vietnam and you know
used
and she did
she was very attractive she was
considered the most beautiful woman in
the world
and intelligence
yes
but you know i i very much um
i very much am interested in the
intersection of tech and entertainment
and so you know while i would say she
was pre web one you know who's the wi-fi
she created wi-fi you know she's but she
never got any money from her she's not a
dime no she didn't i mean she these are
the ward didn't they
the whole pattern went to the man
that she co-created with wow and she
never saw a dime from it they called it
bluetooth
it's bluetooth now yeah yeah okay and
wi-fi but
um yeah i mean it was such a shame
because later in her life you know my
last name is goldman legally i changed
it to lamar when i found out i was
related to her because i really related
to that i have a very
large science background you know i was
studying breast cancer research at tufts
university medical school i was very
involved in it until i realized that
creativity was the element that i liked
most about science
not necessarily the lifestyle of a
scientist
i was like oh there's no place for humor
here um
i'm like i can't joke around you know
about tumors around these people they're
very sensitive
uh you know supposedly cancer is not
funny so um
i i moved out of that but you know when
i found out i was related to her it made
a lot of sense to me because i have so
many of the same interests of as her you
know including wanting to also have five
husbands
i'm still looking for husband number one
so if anyone's listening to this and
they are six feet taller and
have a large
bank account
hit me up hit me up 818 533 1843 leave a
voicemail the number is that her number
no that's our number
yeah but um
yeah i i've always
at the end of her life
you know i guess some of my cousins
wrote her a letter did i say at the end
of my life
oh good good okay
at the end of her life my cousin sent a
letter saying we'd love to come visit
you she was living floor at the time and
apparently she sent back a letter that
said
money i have time i don't
was ironic because she didn't really
have money at that time either but you
know if i had known that before i
changed my name
i probably wouldn't have changed my name
because it was pretty disappointing to
hear that but i also know that she had
been through the ringer with hollywood
and the old starlet ways that they
treated actresses back in the day and
you know she didn't get any credit for
her work
and i you know gal gadot was playing her
in a mini-series i mean who could be a
better person to play here than the
hottest jewish woman alive beautiful yes
yeah i mean it could have been me but um
other than that
but no i mean i'm very proud of my
heritage and i feel you know very
grateful and lucky that she's in my
bloodline is there anything of hers that
is in the family
that heirlooms of any kind yeah we don't
have anything no no but um
we can always look to the movie ecstasy
i don't know if
she was the first woman nude on film in
a non-pornographic way
and hbo if you're listening i am willing
to show my boobs on camera thank you so
much
[Laughter]
and hbo does listen
i work for hbo myself
um he guild back to you
[Laughter]
but all this is very all this is very
time consuming though
it has to consume your whole all every
day
yeah and my days are pretty jam-packed
you know i record my podcast weekly with
my co-host teddy mellencamp she's
fantastic and i mean joe malinko's
daughter yes
wow and oh actually okay yeah and she's
fantastic
what'd you say from who's your mother
elaine irwin i don't know her mom yeah
she's a model
yeah i mean teddy is gorgeous and she's
funny and she's fantastic i actually i
mean i just how did you two meet my
heart paired us together wow
yeah i heart thought that we would be a
good match for each other and they were
right and what's the fascination with
true crime i bet everybody did i i mean
i
asked gil because i have a fascination
with trump i i just seek answers
i i cannot live in the gray i can't have
anything go without an answer you know
so with the robert durst case when they
finally decided obviously he had
murdered her but when they finally
closed the case and said that he was the
murderer
and then he obviously passed away
recently
oh at least we got closure you know
conviction
but he was quite um
elusive mentally and and physically yes
pretending to be a woman yes in
galveston chopping the body up having
the body come back up mm-hmm but they
never found the head right no see but
also signing crime yeah i'm telling you
but also signing as a woman and living
as a woman yeah
and uh killing the guy from the
from the apartment that how could you
think he wasn't the murderer with all i
mean it's so obvious what about that he
came down to to hollywood hollywood
hills and snuffed out his friend
oh it shot her execution style
and then and then drifted off and they
had they couldn't prove he was here but
they could prove that he was in
california right northern california for
the holidays yeah
i mean it's just somebody i don't know
this is fascinating ruthless yeah i know
you're ruthless you're an advocate for
two experts we're about to watch it
listening to her
yeah northern california i want to know
your take on jonbenet ramsay
uh you know
jonbenet ramsey the the cops screwed it
up for you that would be it because it
was snowing you would think it would be
even though it was snowing that's so
impressive christmas eve
they did i i am sorry i wouldn't be
afraid to say it to them they obviously
know by now too many people were in were
out they didn't control anything you
know for the father to find his daughter
down there the way they and then carry
her up the stairs no that's all
it just don't you don't you think a lot
of crime scenes mysteriously are
mishandled
if they're not
expert you know i say back then yes
people if people if you don't have a lot
of murders
you can't just throw somebody in there
on a murder investigation very technical
very scientific and you got to take
every precautionary measure you can to
preserve what is in the crime scene what
about john f kennedy
and he returned to bethesda
a medical examiner who had never done an
autopsy did his autopsy well the first
mistake was taking him to the bethesda
yeah yeah and he's not supposed to leave
dallas until then
exactly and the coroner tried to stop
them there in dallas pulled guns on him
exactly so it was
it was just wrong i i don't believe i
saw a documentary and they ended up
getting sued behind it
uh with um
dr henry lee
it was a prosecutor dr henry lee
uh
forensic scientist you know they had a
bunch of people on there or five people
four or five people on there
and they broke it down and who they
thought really did the jonbenet
and i've lectured uh dr henry lee and i
i consider him a friend you know we've
lectured together he's he came out here
to look at
one of my cases
and
uh
he's he thinks what happened whether
it's right or wrong
is he thinks
the sibling the little boy killed hit
the hit the daughter
and then they just tried to cover up for
the boy well did you see the cbs
documentary that the family sued them
for almost a billion dollars and i think
he got 750 million the sun
because it was defamation but it
literally sealed the public's opinion
that he had murdered her
and we've seen in interviews how he
seemed a little cold or laughing or
smiling while he's being interviewed
about his sister
and of course that could be for a number
of reasons
you know a lot of time has passed don't
ever personality whatever that i do
i trust pay attention to the most
and follow the science they screwed it
up you know the investigation from the
beginning
was bad it's kind of hard to go back and
try to clean up after somebody screwed
it up as bad as they did well there was
a ransom note that they had written and
and they found that there was already a
practice note that had been thrown away
who has time to write a practice note
when you're
i mean it seems that it could have been
an inside job but
you know for the sake of not wanting to
be sued by the family and then you don't
know how influential they are
you know who's running the investigation
and when you get
something at a small town people that
aren't used to this
it's overwhelming for them right you
know really this it was very
overwhelming the stuff they were putting
out
just as an example
the uh actor that shot fired the gun on
the set by accident uh
alec baldwin
it's very obvious to me just watching
what i was saying
that the local law enforcement are not
used to
high-profile cases
so the stuff they're releasing on the
news oh no don't say that don't say this
you know
it's just
letting the media run their
investigation and then you can't do it
like that why do you think they don't
send in professionals immediately on
these high-profile cases because the
local cities
uh don't want big brother coming in you
know they want to thank everybody's
professional hey i got detectives that
can do that and unless
uh
they're prepared clearly now i think
they said that with dna they could solve
the john b ramsey case
that's what they were saying but then
they said you know they found multiple
people's dna in her underwear and then
they said no it could have been from the
factory that created the underwear
and it's also like how far back is the d
why was this not done
when it i mean i have so many questions
about that also kill real fast do you
have any like get out of jail free
passes i wish i did keep me out of jail
have you been to jail no
not yet
okay so that one is still
that one is still going i mean it could
be solved i mean i hope that ramsay's
gone i think maybe john ryan is still
alive
yeah the mom passed and then brothers
yeah i'm sorry to see the mom pass
because you think that she would have
everybody i think she had knowledge
yeah maybe she did because i think maybe
sure well people say on the 911 call
they heard her say what did you do
in the background referencing and and
there was some mixed messaging between
oh no the brother was sleeping and then
oh no you know he was awake and you
could hear him in the background and you
know there was a lot of mixed messages
but she still had pineapple in her
stomach and there was pineapple sitting
out with fingerprints on it with the
brother
you two could hook up and solve the case
i don't know about the pineapple
i had a very close personal friend of
mine who works for the fbi was actually
called and spent time helping out on the
investigation oh wow uh
and he's a brilliant man he spent the
last
probably the last three months of ted
bundy's life with ted bundy you know he
was his uh his main man
and he ended up
with him on a daily basis and talking to
stuff and
he ended up taking over for bundy's
attorney you know just to make things
settled in the end they became friends
like and yeah
uh
so i don't know i i do know
that unless you're
on it from the beginning you have inside
information you have access to files or
evidence it's it's so tough because the
news media
and even documentaries they slant things
to make it they want to bring you unhook
you in
so you can think one way
and then it may or may not be the truth
so i don't pay too much attention to
uh cases like that anymore because
i don't know what they've got to work
with i was excited about the golden
state killer from
from california the old guy would have
but he didn't hit nelly county hit
orange county hit northern california
didn't in l.a county didn't know any
cases but those things still he knew you
were there that's right you would have
solved it we never caught the zodiac
killer that's right i have a question
for you yes ma'am i've always wondered
this and it is so baffling to me
why would someone who didn't commit the
murder claim that they committed the
murder oh we get those all the time all
the time and i don't get it people are
that are not
let's just say not with the full
faculties
they want uh you know they'll get some
recognition and they'll just be
demanding they're about four or five
people that came and tried to con
confess to the night stalker you know
had absolutely nothing to do yeah i did
yeah and most of them are mental mental
problems they just want attention or
mental you know because i remember when
i read about the black dahlia case
and i remember that this had so many
people coming forward that they said
that they had murdered her when in fact
they hadn't
that case went unsolved right well
officially it's still unsolved they
haven't but officially solved it but it
sounds like we know the answer huh yeah
wait
there was a guy that was a dentist it
was the dentist for sure right i don't
know i don't know i remember dennis
doctor we dissected the case when i was
going through this like her body was
even at sunset
i believe my father
i found the tools he found the equipment
bag with stuff
yeah it had to have been a skilled
surgeon
certainly that and that we did it uh
when i was going to cal state l.a this
advanced criminal class that i took on
sex crimes
we went through the black value case we
had files access to files and stuff like
that
uh a very good friend of mine who worked
on a case
uh john st john from lapd
uh
so there there's stuff there and
why it never got officially solved i
don't know because i don't work lapd
yeah what do we know about uh charles
manson
oh
one more question before we get into
before we get into that he died before i
got a chance to see him
one more question yes yeah yeah i just
you know
i feel like i could ask you a million
questions
like i'm so sick of this i would i would
like
i would allow you a million in one
[Applause]
as long as i buy you an nft say hi this
is kill i made a comment last week
aaron grabbed the timestamp
do you find that most serial killers had
very troubled childhoods
i don't know because i haven't
interviewed
that many serial killers i said yes
or
had
mothers or fathers that were that
did things you know like the green river
killer's mom
wore the robe open
in the house and you know no no kid
should see that you know i gave him a
bath with a robe on
and it was open and his mind became you
know you see that kind of stuff it's oh
that i'm taking notes so if i ever have
a child they're not supposed to see my
name
close
rough clothes wait really oh yeah this
explains a lot of my trauma okay wait
yeah
i mean it is all related back to things
you shouldn't see i always say
my daughter is 25 and i would tell my
wife
you you can't unsee something so we
would try to make her
make it the house so you wouldn't see it
because it's hard to unsee it well this
is why i heard foot fetishes come about
because it's not me if i'm wrong
i'm gonna say yes
but apparently it's the first time you
see your mother naked you feel shame so
you look down and you see her feet and
then you identify sex with feet
okay
i'll i'll be the first to say this i'll
be the second one i've
i've got a foot fetish but my mother did
not have pretty feet i'm gonna tell you
that right now you should take a look at
mine then
i basically don't have pinky toes she
didn't
and then i know that i'm not bad
mouthing my mom but and i never saw my
mom naked so i so i don't know but i
know well she didn't have pretty feet in
san fernando california in the 60s there
was an actress by the name of donna reed
oh yes we had a lingerie the donna
there we go it was quite
stunning
and she had a lingerie store in the san
fernando mall donna reads
and you would go in there and she was
working in the store and looked
impeccable
and i would look down and i would see
her in her heels with her stockings with
a line in the back
and it was quite mesmerizing for a young
boy to see that wow and especially
because her pictures from her movies
were all around on top of the dressing
rooms all around the store so you would
see her there
and then you would look up and then you
would look down and you're making those
associations
even so even my wife is aware of the
fact that i have
uh
you could be the most beautiful lady in
the world
and if you don't have ugly feet kill
won't touch yeah if you have ugly feet
what's considered a good foot pop it out
there sis oh i've already seen them
they're good i've already seen them
they're clean they're mad
toenail polish white daddy white ribbon
trust me it's covering the cells no
what's considered ugly feet
uh i don't know you got to see them and
then you say oh yeah that's
not that's definitely not nft material
right there you know you just
uh
you know they're they're clean well
manicured and
uh
so you like fungus
we're
girls with fungus feet and
it's always the [ __ ]
what does george you had dirty feet dry
you know
you know the nails gone
you're into that oh oh no
that's fast
you know as busy as you are
uh well manicured fingernails as well
you know everything's all there that's
why i said it's hard for me to vision
you
up on stage as a comedian thank you
also my parents and i mean that but not
with an open road
hello thank you yeah i mean i've been
doing stand up six years
and i know that's almost like a baby but
i spent the last year
essentially in it you know touring every
weekend and dane cook takes me out eric
griffin takes me out chris redd takes me
out you know i i've been very fortunate
um and i just started headlining
and thank you you know and it's uh
it's a it's obviously a labor of love
and it's uh the other lady that's it's
quite an opportunity to learn none of
those guys oh angela johnson i just met
her
nice lady incredible beautiful hilarious
she is
and
that's what you're the only two ladies
in comedy seriously
that
how did they do this you know i
i feel comedian working smoke-filled
everybody getting drunk so it's going to
age you and
well i don't drink so i'm actually 90. i
just take really good care of myself you
don't look a day over 80 in the uh yeah
in the 80s uh
when i would work in the clubs i would
leave my clothes outside overnight
because when i got back to the condo
they smell like cigarettes
yeah yeah i don't i don't drink or smoke
i only do coke sherman molly because i
care about my skin
[Laughter]
yeah that's awesome yeah but i thank you
gil i know what you're saying and i
appreciate it yeah you're very welcome
who are your influences in comedy
where do i start ali wong is probably
one of my favorites to watch and there's
something very magical about her life
and i i mean her specials are great as
well obviously but i i really learned a
lot from her i remember i was about to
go up in the main room of the comedy
store and she just tapped me on the back
and i was like [ __ ] i'm getting bumped
by allie wong you know and then i had to
follow her but
i find her hilarious you know
women who talk about subjects
like child birth and child rearing in a
way that is relatable to everyone across
the board i think is very difficult to
do and still make it funny to everyone
um i just cherish her comedy i think
she's hilarious obviously schumer paved
the way for a lot of women but if we
take it back one step further joan
rivers is probably
maybe my number one icon strong jewish
woman
i remember going to see the documentary
about her when i was a teenager i was
the youngest person in the theater by
landslide and i saw him throughout the
entire documentary because i felt like
she was so misunderstood
she was so hilarious and so hard working
and so generous and everyone just kind
of saw her as a shrewd
tough
you know woman but what she did was she
created a path for so many other women
to say whatever they wanted on a stage
and be taken seriously
um so i've always loved her and you know
did i audition to play maisel and not
get it and now there's a non-jew
playing maisel sure am i still bitter
about it i don't know you tell me
i don't think you're the only one either
i've seen think pieces oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah no but rachel rajnan is
incredible actor she is
she i mean she just makes that
role shine but uh so joan was obviously
a very big influence in my life and i
was very fortunate right before the
pandemic i was um guest hosting on a
show on e called what the fashion
which was essentially fashion police and
i love roasting so for me it was just i
was just roasting fashion constantly
um which was like a dream job it was
like a dream job for me you know and i
used to do the roast battles and love
jeff ross and everyone over there so
it's like this is a dream
um but obviously chappelle chris rock i
remember watching
i can't even i couldn't even tell you a
joke from his hbo special i just
remember his smile and his contagious
laughter and thinking he's the coolest
person on the planet
and that just filled me
just even thinking about it fills me
with joy
i remember watching robin williams stand
up and how dirty it was
and i remember there's just this like
one joke again i was like a kid where
he'd bury his arm his face in between
his elbow to show that he was eating a
woman out
and then you know i idolized now as an
adult the fact that he would go from
being such a dirty comic to then being a
clean family man on
film yes and that he was able to work
both
and i think jim carrey is similar to
that too where he's someone who can blur
the lines of stand-up comedian and then
tv film actor
and you know i've always hoped for
myself that sort of career where i would
go from in between going i i couldn't
see myself not performing like i i
there's no world in my
vision where i'm not doing stand up but
going back and forth between tv film and
and stand-up would be my dream
would be my dream completely jeez it
sounds like somebody i know
grant
he's out there doing that yeah that's
that's me i'm on me no that's good
that's uh it's awesome you know i
remember um
[Music]
joan rivers had a uni royal commercial
in the early 70s that uh i found her
quite attractive
and i told her when i had my tongue show
that i found her quite attractive and
she said what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
i said i don't know i thought you were
hot
you know it's interesting because i also
i loved phyllis diller
and
um
i had a web series many years ago
okay not to brag um i had a web series
many years ago and i i cast this
woman who is her name is bunny and she
was in the original american band stand
she's incredible she's she's like a
grandma to me
and she gave me at um we had a premiere
uh at the chinese theater was amazing
she gave me a book by phyllis diller
lampshade in a whorehouse
that was signed by phyllis
and she gave it to me and she said i
feel like you should have this
because i see so much of phyllis in you
and i just started saying wow
congratulations and it was such a heart
i mean it was such a heartfelt moment
for me to
for someone else to see that in me and
connect the pieces and then give me this
piece of history essentially i was just
so honored blown away
are you phyllis steeler and
john rivers and wow
betty white
and
all that who else
who else is it lily tomlin wow
yep
well you know i did i've been around a
long time i didn't i did melissa's
podcast a few years back now and when i
met melissa i just started crying i was
like i love you
she was very sweet very sweet lady yeah
you know one one of the i mean the whole
can we talk and the whole heart facade
was
what she had to do and then you know
edgar
was a bit of somebody that really didn't
i mean once they didn't have her back it
was just a different kind of having her
back you know the whole tonight show
thing kind of frazzled them and
you know
kind of bailed on her yeah yeah that's
true
and
we lost gail
and uh yeah you know what's interesting
because
yeah that's what i heard i i heard he's
going to vr porn
say hello to the amazons i uh drill two
holes in that wall
pop out right through right there
wow how big is gil's day
um you know it's crazy
seven years ago i moved to la but i live
in new york and i i started staying up
in l.a not new york which is crazy the
last thing i did before i moved here was
i went to gotham
and i saw harlan williams on stage
and i thought this is the funniest
person i've ever seen live oh my god
i'll never be able to do that that was
my thought i'll never be able to do that
then i moved to la and i thought i was
going to be a young ingenue and star
wars movie i don't know mentally ill
delusional delusional right and i met
with this casting director and after
chatting with her for an hour she goes i
want to let you know you're more funny
less pretty
oh wow and i was like oh my god how did
that you think i'm funny
you know i knew what she meant what she
meant was there a lot of beautiful women
in la i'm not a 19 year old model you
know and if you're funny and you're a
female you should capitalize on that
because there are fewer people in that
pool than the attractive girl in la pool
you know uh yeah you know i think that
um
you know if you are a bit
different you know where everybody was
trying to be the same but if you try to
be a bit
different you have a clearer path not
that the path is clear but you have
a bit of a different point of view than
everybody else like you know my
i never thought i'd be on tv or 20 years
later still have the show run but my
thoughts were different than everybody
else's i wasn't trying to be like
anybody else so i kind of established
myself as
kind of observation but of a family that
really didn't exist i put it together
yeah so and then getting somebody behind
you that you know supported you and said
i like this what this guy's doing but
there's no guarantee so i just
you know we get lucky there's a lot of
guys that
uh before when communities were getting
shots made 20 years ago that
looked like they had everything going
for them and then
two bad weeks and then they're gone i
mean it's all it's all a bit of a
of a of um
obstacle course that mm-hmm you hope you
you can or a demolition derby where you
hope your car keeps running after you
know taking hits but it's it's it's it's
not easy and it's just a lot of work and
you worry about [ __ ] every day but
it's pretty cool
i mean i did see that you have a pilot
with my with my daughter young amazing
we're casting some actors tonight at six
six thirty okay well i'll be there so um
i think he would be great for the i
think it would be great for her
veterinarian's office
i mean for me and coach i'm ready yeah
all right i'll make sure you guys are
connected yeah
and i have my original creator the guy
that uh did my first show with wow
you know and
obviously you know we're just meeting in
person for the first time but that's a
true testament to your character because
there are so few people who continue to
work together after an original project
you know there was two guys i wanted to
work with
one was matt williams he did
home improvement and cosby oh my god and
uh the second was bruce
so the two guys i didn't even know
either of them yeah and i got to work
with both both of the guys wow
i called matt today because he's in the
cosby documentary on showtime and i was
going to say that could not have been an
easy interview to sit for
he handles up very well yeah i haven't
watched it yet have you watched it it's
pretty tough yeah
is it a series or is it just one like
movie before okay
got my homework cut out for me tonight
after my audition obviously but um
i would say i would have to have
considered him a friend
but a new friend not
but still
man it's
heavy it's oh yeah i mean it's
what do they call nefarious criminal of
the highest level you know
oh god it's so dark it's
vince champ was a was a guy who in the
80s
was a comedian who was kind of like that
like
not
not a black comedian in in body but not
in mine and he
went from college to college and he was
raping
co-eds from college to college
and
i think somebody he was on a cruise ship
when they kind of identified him and
then he got off the ship in miami and
they arrested him and i don't think he's
been out of jail since probably mid 80s
i think even in jail there's a hierarchy
where if you're a rapist
people hate you
right they'd prefer for you to be a
murderer than a rapist
and he would say when he was conducting
his deed
he had a mask on he would lift the mask
up and he would say pray for me
wow so it was during coverage
very good very good
number two he's been gone
and i hate to be time cop but we gotta
wrap it up oh my god so this was uh
almost an hour and 20. and we got two
today so man we didn't even get to
really
i want to be on your crime podcast yeah
you guys got to come up there i know a
lot about crime yeah come on whenever
you want can i say that uh in charles
manson's last interview yes they said to
him how do you spend your time these
days and he said i'm a lover of classic
rock
i'm a i'm a big fan of frank sinatra
john wayne and george lopez
and how do you feel about that
you know it's pretty awesome it's pretty
[ __ ] amazing
god that's so pretty amazing isn't it
yeah it's sick and it's amazing
uh do you wanna tell the people where to
find you follow you what to check out
yeah don't follow me to my car but you
can follow me online i'm at leah
lamar.com for show dates
thank you so much instagram lia lamar
twitter lia lamar and if you see
leolamar.eth it's still me uh and then
if i still have a tick tock by tomorrow
it's leo lamar with five r's why don't
ask questions how long are you supposed
to be tick-tock a day they said i'm
banned forever
but a couple days but but my account is
still popping right now so i don't even
know if the ban is real it's very
confusing and i'm heartbroken if you
can't tell don't you know anybody over
there
great lots to offline about here yeah
well you know uh basically i i deleted
all my covid videos and then i started
deleting all the anal videos and i
started deleting all the vagina videos
and the dick videos
[Laughter]
yeah wow yeah well you know i'm still an
anal virgin not to brag like i said
don't follow me in my car but um
do people do identify themselves as the
annual virgin stuff i think one does at
least one i'm saving something for my
husband
i don't have a tower
[Laughter]
oh boy well thank you for coming out
thank you for having me oh you're the
best you're the best this has been a
blast goes by so fast when you're uh
when you're having fun yeah
but the crime is uh yeah me too i don't
know why maybe are you an only child no
do i have only tylenol energy no no but
sometimes only children look at weird
[ __ ]
it's funny when you asked about like
alleged do serial killers all have like
a messed up childhood it's like serial
killers and comedians
my mom bought me a playboy when i was 12
years old for a bus ride from sacramento
to l.a [ __ ] me up is that what she got
you that hoodie too
hilarious yeah he's been a member ever
since
they just sent you merch every year i
mean you know i've been through the
whole thing but then watching that
i mean listen i think we're gonna find
out if we go back and dig in time that
the people
uh
everybody was a little bit about
themselves yeah
mumbai had seven girlfriends who's in
the seven was he mormon or
just you have nerves just just rich get
out [ __ ] you're blocking the light
awesome he was he was not you know i
mean
you know my mom one of my
hugh hefner i used to work at the
playboy jazz festival
and they said mr hefner you know hasn't
been well
and he's going to be uh you know coming
to the
there's he'll be sitting in the front
he's not going to stand up he wants you
to do somebody's not going to stand up i
said i'll give this [ __ ] an
introduction
that will make him stand up and he stood
up hey i laid it on that's awesome and i
you know my thing is
i do pretty good introductions yeah so i
said watch this i'll get his ass and he
just was like creaking and he
stood i said i got him to stand up six
women raised them all
there's
to me but you know i yeah you can
imagine i mean just
a lawlessness there
wow
welcome back gil thank you we missed you
and bill cosby did the jazz festival and
he gave me the job at the jazz festival
and there was some
luxury there you know what's so crazy is
these how could he be so hilarious and
and so
broken yeah evil evil pure evil you know
that's just
it's like you don't have to go through
all that anyone would [ __ ] you
you know it's true it probably i think
it becomes you know he was if you look
at that showtime
he was a bartender at temple
and he was funny but a bartender sure
maybe an african-american bartender so
the guy said you should do stand-up and
i think he did that and i think it's
controlled in a way that
yeah is
you know amazing
well i always love to end podcasts on a
high note
thank you darlene oh thank you so much
for having me you guys this has been a
blast
you